speaking of squeezing an extra couple
bucks out of people
guess what guess what's happening this
this week
Prime day Prime day for All America can
save money by spending billions yep
spend spend money save money let me
think oh it's a trick
yep so what are the what are the stats
on Prime day I'm gonna turn you into an
analyst kellyanne I'm I'm ready for it
so in 2021
um uh consumers spent 11.19 billion
dollars on Amazon Prime day and last
year in 2022 they spent only 12 billion
dollars only a little bit more and they
saved 1.7 billion dollars you guys spent
12 billion and then you saved 1.7 so
good job for you all right what do the
analysts think this year is going to be
um that is a great question yes do
analysts forecast Prime day so do you
buy itself on Prime day
um I I see if there's something I need
or that's useful but I'm very opposed to
buying things just to buy things to say
that I save money exactly no no that
doesn't happen at our house at our house
it's like hey we buy according to need
yep and we go on a it was like
Bailey wanted to buy these sneakers you
know that Nike makes a Air Jordan
knockoff of their own sneakers didn't
you know that no I had no idea they're
yeah it's a lower it's a lower price
point shoe that looks a lot like Air
Jordan Ones okay um and there's a little
bit of a platform-ness to it and stuff
so it's it's a different shoe but it's
supposed to look like AJ ones yep and
she likes them because they're gray or
they're light blue and she said I'm
going to look around and find out where
I can get them and Walmart had them of
all places interestingly is Walmart or
you know DSW or something okay but she
didn't go running down the Foot Locker
and she didn't go to the Nike website
because I push on them I say look
we buy according to need but you got to
do your research and be a really smart
consumer and also be be very careful
from buying it off weird you know uh
websites storefronts on eBay because
you're buying knockoffs yep and so
that's what we do so when it comes Prime
day it's not like that spend you know
but we do a little bit a little bit more
sensibility than that you know we don't
need 12
jars of the same peanut butter because
you you could save three dollars though
you could save three dollars and you
have enough peanut butter to last until
grandchildren are born you know but I
mean I'm not sure I need that if you can
get a second and a third air fryer and
save 400 bucks I think that's a good
deal although Bailey's taking an air
fryer to college there you go we have a
joke Bailey walks down to the kitchen
every morning and our joke is I say
Bailey will eat
and Bailey goes anything
she'll have spaghetti so oh there's some
spaghetti left oh hey there's these
things left all of a sudden these things
these uh wontons are in the air fryer
Zoom there she goes and I'm smelling
dinner at 8am I said why don't you have
coffee and like granola like the rest of
us it's like no no I kind of want this
she doesn't eat like this it's just a
small amount but she's looking for
regular stuff so she will so if there's
an air fryer this time next year before
she's heading to for Prime day we may
get her an Air fryer if she's allowed to
take that to school yeah because it's
kind of funny at the school they'll say
you know you can't have no um nothing
that creates heat that can cook can be
in a dorm room okay right is that
microwave stew or no I I don't know
about the microwaves I think microwaves
be okay microwave popcorn those little
90 microwaves that are in a giant stack
at Best Buy you know you know it's just
like a little tiny Samsung it's big
enough for microwave popcorn or ramen
noodles that's what it is and uh but you
know what have you got in what have you
got dorm room uh two underage girls you
know uh ounce of coke and some uh you
know fentanyl okay long as you don't
have a stove you know it's like we don't
want no heat here that's right you know
it's just the way it goes but um
interesting so Prime day is going to be
so big so anyway Amazon one of the five
in the S P 500 probably gonna be a
little a little bit of a pop and then
you've got some Tesla was also yeah the
interesting thing about uh Prime day
though for scale is that as big as we
think Prime day is of 12 billion in a
day I mean that's that's a lot of
transactions uh in China their
equivalents is the singles day and to
take a guess on how much yes take them
take a guess on how much they generate
on their singles day well remember we
have 300 million 330 million people in
the United States yep plus around 30
million people in Canada because Canada
is just a little bigger in California
and I think it's 50 someone correct me
on this 54 million in Mexico so if you
take the North American contingent there
that's what 400 million maybe a little
more than 400 million and whereas
you would need five of those to make the
two billion in China right yeah so let's
see so a prime day is
13 million this year 12 13 times 5.
110 120 140. 140 so it's even bigger so
they're buying even more Yep on a per
capita basis holy moly yeah so so we got
a little bit of a ways to go
140 billion yeah that's a solid number
in a day
you know that's a lot of millions in an
hour do you know how um
you know like American consumers like
you know the fashion brands and the
perception all this is Italian even
though it's all made in China and stuff
I wonder if like do Chinese consumers
want like the American versions of these
products yeah that's that's uh that's a
good question I think that um some of
them maybe but iPhones were big in in
China and Tesla I mean they set up a
factory there and that was one of their
second biggest markets but it also
depends on how much it is first move uh
first movers Advantage versus yep they
just find similar knockoffs and they
they run with those
foreign